à l'heure où chaque mot chaque
expression chaque opinion peut vous
valoir une remontrance des modérateurs
en ligne l'histoire de joe rogan est à
plus d'un titre révélatrice l'animateur
est une véritable vedette aux états unis
le principe de son émission un ton
décontracté et un panel d'invités pour
le moins éclectique joe rogan écoutes
laissent la parole et les rares moments
où il donne son avis ne permettent pas
vraiment de le placer sur l'échiquier
politique
un positionnement qui fait recette
puisque ces podcasts attire sur spotify
11 millions d'auditeurs les problèmes
démarre lorsque joe rogan reçoit des
personnalités du secteur médical dont
les discours tranche avec le consensus
médiatique autour du colis de 19,2
émission lui valent notamment une
avalanche de critiques en décembre joe
rogan reçoit tour à tour un médecin
texan affirmant que la vaccination est
responsable de la mort de milliers de
personnes puis robert malone pionnier de
la technologie de la rn messager est
également opposé à la vaccination des
enfants
cet épisode en particulier va attirer
les critiques de plus de 250 médecins et
scientifiques
il adresse une lettre ouverte à spotify
la plateforme qui hébergeait podcast
le docteur malone a utilisé le podcast
de joe rogan pour promouvoir de
nombreuses affirmations sans fondement
notamment plusieurs mensonges sur les
vaccins contre le coc vie 19 et une
théorie infondée selon laquelle des
dirigeants ont type nautiz et le public
beaucoup de ces affirmations ont déjà
été discrédité ce n'est pas seulement un
problème scientifique au médical c'est
un problème sociologique aux proportions
dévastatrice et spotify est responsable
en permettant à cette activité de
fleurir sur sa plateforme et puis ce
sont des artistes tels que n'ayons
qu'est menace si spotify n'intervient
pas alors ils souhaitent retirer ses
morceaux de la plateforme les millions
indique ne pas vouloir être associés
d'une façon ou d'une autre au discours
exprimé dans les podcasts de joe rogan
prenant la tête d'une fronde de quelques
artistes le musicien va même jusqu'à
demander aux salariés de spotify de
démissionner en signe de protestation
car l'entreprise malgré les pressions a
décidé de maintenir l'émission seuls
quelques épisodes ont été supprimés car
des termes tendancieux et insultant ils
ont été prononcées joe rogan a
d'ailleurs présenté ses excuses sur ces
faits mais sur leur est pas question de
céder aux demandes de censure daniel eck
le pdg de la plateforme suédoise reste
ferme malgré les attaques ad hominem
voici ce qu'on peut lire de sa part dans
une lettre qu'il adresse à ses employés
si je condamne fermement ce que jo a dit
et que j'approuve sa décision de retirer
des épisodes de notre plateforme je
réalise que certains veulent davantage
et je veux dire une chose très
clairement je ne crois pas que réduire
jo aussi dense et la réponse nous
devrions avoir des lignes claires sur
notre contenu et agir quand elles sont
franchies m'effacer des voix est une
pente glissante
cette pente glissante c'est celle de la
censure des géants du numérique qui
n'ont pas hésité à effacer supprimés et
bannir de leurs plateformes des propos
considérés comme de la désinformation
des décisions souvent controversées
particulièrement lorsqu'il s'agit du coc
vie de 19 et que les certitudes d'hier
ne sont plus celles du lendemain c'est
d'ailleurs l'angle adopté par joe rogan
dans une vidéo postée sur instagram est
visionnée près de 9 millions de fois
le problème que j'ai avec le terme de
désinformation surtout aujourd'hui c'est
que beaucoup de choses que nous
considérions comme de la désinformation
il ya peu de temps sont maintenant
acceptées comme des faits par exemple il
ya huit mois
si vous disiez qu'en étant vaccinez vous
pouvez toujours attraper le coc vider le
propager on vous aurez banni de
certaines plateformes maintenant c'est
juste accepter comme un fait si vous
disiez je ne pense pas que les masque en
tissu fonctionne vous étiez banni des
réseaux sociaux maintenant c'est
ouvertement répété en boucle sur cnn si
vous disiez je pense qu'il est possible
que le coc u19 proviennent d'un
laboratoire vous étiez là aussi banni de
nombreuses plateformes et réseaux
sociaux maintenant c'est en couverture
de magazine toutes ces théories qui ont
été proscrites à un moment donné ont
juste débattue par les deux intervenants
sur mon podcast ces deux mêmes
aujourd'hui accusé de désinformation
dangereuse je ne sais pas s'ils ont
raison je ne sais pas car je ne suis ni
docteur ni scientifique je me suis juste
assis et j'ai discuté avec ces personnes
soutenues ou construits et joe rogan a
lancé sans doute malgré lui un nouveau
débat sur la liberté d'expression en
ligne une liberté de plus en plus menacé
par la toute puissance des gars femme
qui semble parfois vouloir imposer leur
propre définition de la vérité à l'heure
où de nouvelles plateformes tente
d'offrir des alternatives au monopole
des géants du secteur l'animateur avait
reçu des propositions plus qu'alléchante
pour héberger son podcast ailleurs que
sur spotify car cette affaire est aussi
l'histoire de gros sous et les revenus
conséquents engendrés par ce podcast ont
sans doute pesé dans la décision de le
maintenir en ligne